All right, you're done.
I hope you don't mind that I gave you
the larger table this time.
But it depends on the first one,
so it would've been hard to give you
in any other order.
I gave you the content value structure,
so it's pretty easy
to just insert the data.
Then, we query the data back out.
If move to first fails, the cursor is empty,
and the query failed.
Lots of cut and paste here.
It is nice to fetch the db values
using the Helper for the data type,
although its not strictly necessary,
since we know our test data is actually
going to match our constraints.
There is one more failure case
we need to add here,
if our query doesn't return any rows.
And that's it.
All that just to get a database
and a way to test it.
Now let's run the test again.
Well, at least we know
all the basic stuff works,
and just remember, without these tests,
you wouldn't have been able
to run this code
for a very, very long time.